Good morning, Hank, it's Friday.
Earlier this week, I was like,
"I got attacked by a baby."
Well Hank, in the intervening few days, I have, as you can see, been attacked by a giant baby.
So I'm just sitting around and I see this giant baby pulling himself on the ground,
crawling toward me
and crawling toward me
and then bam!
Giant baby attack.
Or maybe I fell off my bike and broke a rib.
Anyway Hank, I don't think I've ever shown you my backyard,
which, as you can see,
looks astonishingly like Sonoma, California.
[John laughing]
[Hank]: I hope we don't have to film that one again.
That hurt.
[John]: Are you okay?
[H]: I'm fine.
It was slippery.
It was wet.
I  just shot down that like a...
Like a...
[J]: ...like a shooter down a chute thing.
[H]: All of my-
all of my...
analogies were poop based.
[H]: Brotherhood 2.0 recreation moment!
[J]: So Hank and I here in Sonoma, California;
we are here for Dad's 60th birthday party.
[H]: Dad, come on in to the...
[J]: Dad?
is not here
because mom, uhh,
broke her ankle
and so Mom and Dad couldn't come.
So,
we are celebrating Dad's 60th birthday
without them.
[J]: Anyway, Mom and Dad....
[H]: Happy birthday Dad.
[J]: We love you,
and sorry that you are not here with us.
[H]: John almost couldn't come
because he hurt himself very badly.
[J]: We already covered that.
[H]: Show everyone.
[J]: So, today's video is going to be a quick one
because we have to go do stuff
that honors our dad on his 60th birthday.
[H]: At wineries.
[J]: Exactly
and also because we want to go inside
and enjoy the amazing place
that we have rented,
that Mom and Dad can't enjoy
[Hank laughing]
[J]: with its amazing window shades of amazing
and also with the world's quietest fridge.
[H]: You're very impressed by the fridge.
[J]: It's so quiet!
[H]: I like the barbecue,
you could- you could have-
like have an entire pig on it.
[J]: Okay, so, but last night,
Hank and I were talking about the fact that we both have
thousands and thousands of outstanding friend requests on Facebook,
because Facebook believes that you can only have 5,000 friends.
[H]: Yes.
[J]: Facebook does not understand the internet.
[H]: It does not understand Nerdfighteria.
[J]: So, our solution is
that we have changed our Facebook pages
to pages that can have more than 5,000 friends,
so now if you want to be friends with us,
you can - link in the doobly-doo.
[J]: And lastly,
even though I have a broken rib,
have I mentioned that to you Hank?
[H]: You have mentioned it to me.
The worst- which is worse:
coughing or hiccuping?
[J]: Uhhh....
Last night I got the hiccups
and it was like torture.
You made me laugh.
What was the joke? I can't remember.
[H]: Oh, it wasn't something we can tell nerdfighters.
[J]: Well hold on. I'm gonna- I'm gonna pause the camera,
Hank's gonna retell me the joke
and then I'll tell you if we can tell it.
[both laughing]
[J]: We can't tell you.
Definitely. Yeah.
Even though I have a broken rib
and I was attacked by a giant baby,
we are thinking about doing some exercises
while we're here over the weekend,
but we need YOUR
exercise suggestions.
Specifically,
NERD exercises.
[H]: Yes, I just recently had an idea.
[H]: That's a stretch called:
I've dropped something behind the desk.
Ehhh
It's like uh-
It's- I think it might be a zip drive.
I don't even know why I still have that thing.
[J]: Uhhhh
do you have your phone in your pocket?
[H]: Um no, why?
[Hank laughing]
[J]: WIN.
Hank -
I will see you on Monday.